[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off-the-record where we talk
about whatever we want and it's an all
girl's day always go we are what would
you want us to do I don't know what do
you want what do you want just be like
yeah yeah
yeah I know I know it's just like yes
sound like in how I Met Your Mother it's
the show and like basically they talk
about how like there's whoo girls and
they tend to be younger and like so
they're always like woo like going out
to bars and taking shots and what's the
first thing you do [ __ ] well now I'm
something I've learned to be a woo girl
because people used to say I was too
depressed looking so they're like you
got to add more excitement and then once
I started wooing I started getting cast
more and things because I look like a
woo girl who doesn't whoa yeah and then
when I started wooing they're like
together yeah dammit yeah we willing in
the like woo girl woo girl energy Oh
like before I was like there'd be an
exciting thing to be like cool like I
wouldn't like woo and then after I got
that like energy it's like and then I
got cast in more things so yeah I think
boy so good at LC using sushi with her
boyfriend Aaron the other day I was like
oh thank you it's cool that I was that
and then I'm like no I'm really like
route way down here yeah there's also
the girls that when they walk into a
room and they run into someone they know
they're like
that's what girl energy yeah what's the
opposite of that when you hide because
that's me Wow Wow I guess when I like
you when I don't I'm just like I go into
Heidi mode but um well how do you have
seen we do that I don't know I just did
my mic I think you do or maybe that's an
oyster hider that's for sure you're that
emoji my red dress oh this one yeah yeah
I do feel that I do sometimes yeah a fun
day because we have a less penis and
then the white girl
one white five white girl I could pass
let's get used to it America and Ringo
well she's you don't know oh my god but
yeah thinking about you guys that I want
to tell you guys if you've ever tried
organic tampons what the [ __ ] but listen
that segue too bad I was gonna ask you
guys because today I was like thinking
and okay so last time I came I was like
gee oh I haven't gotten my period and
you're like oh my god you haven't gotten
your period well when you get organic
tampons like supposedly makes your
period super short
yeah and so like it did make it really
really short it was like only three days
shorter oh my god
I haven't got my period since you guys
when all girls come together you know
that someone's gonna bring up a period
sooner or later
ah it's just what it was weird it's been
like five six weeks and all I wanted to
do this whole time was introduce
Samantha to the crew and then you bring
up the [ __ ] bloody [ __ ] tampons
she didn't say bloody she said you had
in the book there's a lack of blood that
you're selling yeah that's true that's
why one if anyone's been through that
cuz I'm like worried I'm just trying to
bring it Samantha all right go ahead
never tried a Samantha I don't shorten
your period but I'm up in this [ __ ]
right what is the right one I don't know
we don't know know but yet tell us about
yourself all right you guys hello my
name is Samantha I'm from Pomona which
is in the Inland Empire I'm a power
lifter I like to do YouTube and I like
to do hoodrat show my friends Oh any
takers
style 9:43 bidding starts at $100 nobody
else let's go back to temp I'm really
worried now that you guys know what Sam
is no no cuz I've always been a regular
but I just worried because I was like
okay at first it was really good because
it was only like four days I did I
actually send you a picture
because last time I was here just like
take a pregnancy test right now and I
was like no no no no no like I just got
scared so I went to my cousin's and
she's like here's a pregnancy test like
took this has I'm ready to go she does
get pregnant by looking at a man well
she's married
we're hella fertile yeah she confirmed
she's married she has a baby you know so
like just in case I know I don't know if
she's trying for a baby yet but you know
like maybe she wanted to know so she's
like take it I did I'm not pregnant so
that's good
but now I'm like okay so my bruise just
not coming like that's weird
have you been stressed yeah no not
really not that I knew she got a doctor
are you that's scary
a gynecologist yeah it is really scary
since we're gonna get on that topic yeah
I hate they're gonna call it know that
everyone hates the gynecologist which is
unnecessary it seems like well okay so
I've we're gonna get I don't know if
we're gonna get it to that tongue give
us your vagina info okay let me get a
form decision you guys know how like you
hate pop smears yeah I love them I hate
them and so one time I went and they're
like you know I don't know if you guys
have ever gotten this but it's like a
step above a pub yeah yeah so it's a
biopsy so when they find like abnormal
cells yeah they have to take it a step
further
oh okay like scrape off yeah I thought
that's what it papsmear well no okay so
pap smear is just a cotton swab that did
they just swap that I know this I know
this swab yeah but why did you bring
this up it was so bad you guys like when
I got that done they do lost half of the
audience they didn't let me they didn't
let me leave because like my heart rate
was out I was [ __ ] crying and I wasn't
crying like don't touch I was just like
like having a panic attack
yeah did you believe but yeah you do
believe cuz they cut you yeah and so I
hate the I've had I've had a child come
out of my vagina so trust me I've gotten
all of that [ __ ] that's a tricky thing
we had a biopsy done and I had I had the
sub that normal cells and then I had to
get my hold
what is it uterus or would it like the
whole cervix or yesterday's froze it
like to burn it yes yeah they burned my
whole cervix off we hold one he didn't
burn her cervix off there yeah there's a
patch of cells on the cervix they burned
that off no they burned though they
should just shot like the air through my
whole ready the frozen dance within your
whole like the horror by if the cervix
comes off so then all the animals like
you had a period period I didn't but
like yeah it was crazy that should hurt
it was the worst thing ever okay so my
question is why don't they put us to
sleep for that [ __ ] because I'm tired of
feeling it I started change.org I feel
like they should give actually cuz they
don't give a [ __ ]
really dangerous they're like you have
babies out of there you should handle it
I'm gonna get injected for that - I'm
gonna be like put the druggin like I do
not want to feel anything just they just
take that because before you get the
shot at the dentist they give you the
swab with the gel so you shouldn't more
easily
that's it I know it's [ __ ] and they
care about our feelings in there like
it's really really bad do you know
what's crazy - um kind of going off that
a little bit um is when I've had a woman
doctor like gyno or whatever there's no
way more rough yeah yeah cuz like [ __ ]
I know what this feels like I'm like
okay so I've never like going okay just
cuz I always felt weird like yeah are
you trying to like really look at my
goods because they're good I don't want
to see ya but then because they're so
[ __ ] rough I'm like well let me try
out for one of you guys tell me about it
is right it
and I'm it's like the most pleasant [ __ ]
ever cuz I guess he just no I'm not like
that
I don't okay you're a bull or pleasant
but my dude also put his fingers up my
butthole and then everyone's like that's
wrong but it's not wrong actually like
there's some guy knows that do it is I'm
know I like most don't
yeah well yeah I was like did I just get
fingered in my bow or it was like that a
really like a really a procedure survey
the roof so I did that last time on JK
and then everyone that comes is like oh
my god Nikki got finger reefs by every
doctor and I'm like I gotta look - shut
up now so I did in like like it's
optional basically did you have no no my
doctor opted in I didn't choose anything
but he's it's like I just a more
thorough examination will tell you so my
sister just had a she just had a surgery
for what is it called and though endo
for endometriosis okay and so the so
there leechers inside there very painful
- I'm having an ulcer in your inside of
here like organs but they also go to
your rectum so maybe that's why they do
that type of exam because like like no
thank you I don't think I've ever heard
rectum in this room ever
an [ __ ] yeah I mean it's just because
she just went through this whole process
you're using rectum yeah so maybe that's
what that was not we in this
conversation but this conversation is
like over right you wanna talk about
dicks then cuz that's what we usually do
let's do that okay so so dicks big dicks
forced I'm married to one only tonight
yeah you know I I saw an article mid
filming and I thought that this article
said that this woman was married to two
dudes you know hear that I do yeah love
you can you imagine having to satisfy
two dudes no wait wait wait severe
fantasies [ __ ] up whoa I just feel
like a release you're seeing said I'd be
like do all the work I'm gonna be like
this you got it backwards girl by like
imagine having to have sex like twice in
a day because you know like why not at
once they actually they actually work
together no what the [ __ ] out was well I
mean I can you know change their own but
like I just don't got the energy the
documentary with a polygamous
documentary I was watching with the
Mormons um they when they had multiple
wives they actually had separate
apartments for each wife and so like you
would have sex with one like but you'd
spend that day with her and then another
day you would spend with the other wife
in that apartment so I think I'll be
done with that like be one of the wives
of the week so that way I only have to
like take care of it once a week
I thought you mind if you have multiple
husbands no because in your head and
this did I get explicit for you I felt
like but in your head you're stuck in
the day and you're going twice right but
in our heads there we're not doing any
of that we're children and musing on a
sex she said though like that many times
yeah like I just be like Oh twice a week
three times a week we're good you know
he's like I filled my quota I'm done
yeah one husband is good you know I mean
multiple incomes would be great you know
multiple husbands I have multiple income
then duct work but like outside of that
it's too much you know well I think
you're thinking of it as maybe more
traditional how do you thinking about it
um
more I guess like the guys like it's a
lot more support the other way yeah like
so like I don't even that's we don't
have to like do their dishes I don't
have to like you know do all their [ __ ]
cuz they're doing it for each option of
cheating on my first husband basically
Oh someone is just like your your
boy-toy you know you've said like wrap
your head around being with one person
for like 40 years that's a lot you're
okay with being with two people for 40
years no it's better there's at least
like some options you could I think I
want to be done with a husband and a
boyfriend yeah that works but two
husbands is too much like you know like
so much what if they started fooling
around with each other would you be done
with that
yeah I wouldn't would you be down with
that job oh well I wasn't but all the
attention on me I wouldn't I think as
soon as they like start together I'd be
like know me but how cute your husband's
going on a day by husband you know he's
mine zero I heard that Paris Hilton has
and this is old ass news I don't know
you guys could factory I have no [ __ ]
clue but I heard that she has like her
Playboy's like she'll go whatever
countries want to go party in and then
she just hits them up and she pays them
for it like hey you pay them yeah it's
probably like she's a sugar mama
basically yeah maybe like she's just
hiring these cats yeah and then she just
pulls wrong with them parties with them
and then she's like okay I'm leaving
adios no strings attached I feel yeah I
just feel like a lot of times for me at
least like it's a lot of the emotional
connection that I enjoy out of a
relationship yeah so like that feels
superficial you know what I mean cuz
sexy to get it anywhere any of you can
get it like right now you can walk out
and play if you had an emotional
relationship with two people because a
lot of the polygamists they feel that
way yeah yeah they have like a different
like they fulfill different emotional
needs you know yeah emotional and sexual
because I did read about this one couple
that they were married but they had an
open relationship and the girl would go
and get like emotional satisfaction from
guys and then the guy would go get
sexual pleasure from other girls but it
wasn't like the girl generally care
about the sexual pleasure yeah so they
should
like the same love like which no I mean
they have sex with each other
okay I thought okay guy he wanted more
options
ah I see okay then the girl wanted more
emotional I thought like he wasn't
talking to her emotionally a he is she
wasn't having sex yeah like I'm I
decided mastery no I mean they still had
that relationship together but they just
satisfied I guess between like in the
relationship
one aspect wasn't enough for the both of
us so we had to like slip up and say
yeah but I mean like even right now cuz
I feel like all of us are in a
relationship yeah so like okay so the
way you feel about your dude right now
can you imagine going out of your way to
have an emotional connection with anyone
out no it's too much right it's a lot of
work I'm talking about I'm just
defending those people that know like if
I had it like built a specific bond with
my husband like yeah yeah I don't know
like I cuz I'm like just with the sex
thing like that fantasy is pretty cool
like two dudes out two dudes at once but
they'd have to be like dudes that I
don't know at all
yeah and then like not like not two
husbands yeah yeah emotionally I think
that is too but you're speaking from
someone that has the emotional and
physical with one person right right cuz
I if I was not satisfied in one area
then maybe it would be a good supplement
cuz that so doesn't it say I've been in
a relationship where I was satisfied in
one area but I wasn't in the other yeah
going to someone else then did make
sense yeah that makes sense yeah because
you don't want to lose that thing that
you have with that person but then
they're your missiles like a whole
person you want a whole of something
else today you guys I was listening to a
TED talk I throw my story I know if
anyone swiped up by well let me tell you
guys so it was a TED talk talking about
like cheating and basically how cheating
has been since the beginning of time
yeah and basically the reason why people
do it is because we rely on a partner to
be like our spouse or a best friend the
father of her kids like everything and
so not one person can be your every no
they can I think you can
I don't know I'm personally changed over
because I was like maybe it's just in
the movies but then like with my husband
like right now our relationship I feel
very fulfilled in every single area and
I feel like you can find that
time but like like if you want to find
that you can just shop around like again
not even just about finding it either
it's about creating it with that person
yeah yeah that too and like building it
and like yeah but you also do really
enjoy like the girl circle that waveform
I love that you can't get what Steve
Wright that's true but I wouldn't find
out another man either yeah yeah that's
just like a French Shh you've a true now
that's just a friendship and like a like
another kind of love but basically the
podcast was saying how a lot of times
people get out of their marriage not
because they don't love you but because
they want to find that thrill in
themselves and like feel that feeling
again because let's say like and they
actually said it in the podcast once
let's say if we were married and like
somebody died in my family basically
meet I've been with you for 25 years and
I'm like oh my god like I kind of feel
like this is it like is this all that's
gonna happen before I die like my mom
did you know so basically person a and
their relationship goes and seeks that
thrill and they're like oh let me find
that in myself again Oh see that's why I
believe in a [ __ ] face because you have
to get that out of your system yeah yeah
and then do you only have one [ __ ] face
in your life for me yeah and I don't
plan on having another one right well
it's crazy to think about the fact that
like you never know you don't know no
you don't because we change what every
like your body biology changes every 7
yeah kids your hormones change like
things change yeah I don't know I can
only speak from where I am now and where
I have been but like yeah I could
totally
right now imagine a future of the rest
of my life without ever like needing
anything else that's dope that's nice
that's rare I think might not a lot of
people really have that but I think
because a lot of people settle or like
they don't want to develop it or leave
that part the part that they don't want
to develop it or they don't even know
that they can yeah where both parties
don't want to like maybe one does and
this party doesn't you know it's all
like very complicated but yeah I also
feel like a lot of people aren't
emotionally mature enough to even
realize that these things are there you
know a lot of time support just said you
heard me so I'm gonna hurt you back in
any way that I can you know so a lot of
times like trying to understand yourself
enough and doing the work that it takes
to see like okay I need a partner that
does this this and that
and you're not doing this so I have to
leave you it's really hard to leave a
relationship
you're gonna put the shitty one yeah get
to do a lot of psychological work on
yourself for us for sure yeah and not a
lot of people do it when you could
that's when you can recognize when
you're in a fight with somebody and like
oh wait what what part of this is my
fault of the fight and then you like
when you're mature enough to do that
because you know yourself then it helps
the the it helps that and your
relationship can flourish yeah
preach
[Music]
[Music]